Oh,
I had a sister.
There was a very decent wardrobe that was getting very respectable,
close to being complete shit,
man.
Now it's all gone.
All gone.
All gone
in order today is,
it's a blank,
just blank.
White guys like you and I know what to phase this essential to our survival in
the hunter gatherer sense of the word.
No.
What are we doing?
Consumers,
your consumers.
We are byproducts,
lifestyle obsession,
burger crime,
poverty.
He sinks.
Don't concern me.
What concerns me?
A celebrity,
magazines,
television with 500 channels.
Some guy's name on my underwear.
Rogaine game by Agra,
less strength.
Martha Stewart.
Fuck Martha Stewart,
Arthur's policy and Nebraska on the titanic.
It's all going down,
man.
The fuck off with your sofa units and string green stripe pattern.
I say never be complete.
I say stopping.
Perfect.
I say,
look,
let's evolve with the chips fall where they may things you own end up owning.
You
do it.
You're like,
man.
So whenever things were going a little too well,
like on one hand and motivated me to seek success because you can't go out and
glory without success.
Everything was going well and then a system,
it's going to little too well let's keep pushing it pumps and it's basic gets
bigger and bigger and bigger until you're forced to kind of confronted.
So right now,
whatever like a recurring theme,
like another one's like losing weight,
like another part of that self concept was the bad guy,
but also the um,
kind of like dramatic,
like destructive artists.
So a win against me for example,
losing weight,
getting in shape consciously,
I wanted to classes,
I'm like,
fuck yeah,
let's get ripped.
Get subconsciously you was different and your subconscious has been building for
so long,
it'll be stronger than any fucking conscious thought you have.
It's crazy.
It's like consciously think about this consciously,
we would never do anything that is self destructive.
Why the fuck would you cautiously choose to do anything that's self destructive?
You wouldn't,
it's awesome conscious.
You know,
we think like,
how did I end up here?
You got exactly what the fuck you want it subconsciously conscious.
He may think I want a healthy relationships subconsciously.
Same maybe as a kid you associated like,
you know,
love with abandonment.
What's going to happen.
I want her to stay 90%.
Your abandonment equals love.
Going through that kind of made me realize this brought my attention to it and
literally since then I've just been focusing on like what's buried down there.
Like actually sitting down and just jumping deep into my fucking subconscious
and bringing that shit up,
processing it.
And uh,
since then it's like gone extreme.
You fucking in shape and it's like you finally get that lasting shit that you're
after a good way to,
to kind of reconcile self acceptance and self actualization.
It's by knowing deep down inside the,
we're already up here.
The journey is getting rid of everything that's in a way from you realizing
you're up here right now,
what do you feel?
Is there like a knot in your stomach?
Like what the fuck's going on?
Tuning into that?
Not Judging it.
Okay.
We're,
if you're going into your subconscious,
like for example,
replaying a certain experience that was like traumatic and usually like,
again,
you'll fucking cry.
You'll,
you'll feel like horrible.
Like it's replaying that.
Um,
and then really focusing on that feeling.
Like if there's something buried in there,
it's like replay that scenario and let yourself experience that scenario fucking
fully.
It's like you're there.
It's like you're going through that shit and it's really painful.
It's not necessarily a fun process by the way.
You'll go through it and then it's about not judging it,
not labeling it,
not viewing it as bad.
And the only way to do that is to turn off your mind,
like to quiet your mind,
opening up to it,
not resisting it because that's what we're taught as well.
Like anything painful,
it's like resistant.
But here it's like opening up to the pain or softening to the pain,
let's just say.
And then just kind of letting it run its course and you'll realize like just by
kind of breathing and letting yourself experience it,
you can visualize it.
Come up,
come out,
uh,
you'll let go of it.
You're like,
okay,
what the fuck am I feeling?
You know,
when was maybe the last time I felt like this one is the first time I felt like
this.
And that's an interesting thing too with your subconscious is the more awareness
you bring to it.
At first you'll just have like little bursts of what was stuck there.
And uh,
it's like overtime that you slowly kind of allow yourself to let more out
the way they're,
the way you grow is by realizing you're already there and getting rid of
everything,
telling you you're not there.
That's the journey.
If you get that and you let go of trying to feel happy
because you don't want to feel happy,
you want to be happy,
not the emotion but the state.
Fuck the emotion.
You do not want that emotion because as I said,
that emotion is out to your happiness.
That emotion is dependent on something and it's linked to feeling happy,
feeling not happy.
What makes you feel happy eventually will turn into unhappiness.
You don't want to feel happy.
You want to let go of Shit that makes you feel happy cause that's the shit
you're attached to you.
You want to let go of anything you want.
You want to let go of anything you don't want.
Let go of all the emotions that go of all the thoughts reached the state,
and again,
you can't put the state in towards,
but that's what we're looking for because you've all had the emotional feeling
happy.
It's clearly is not what you're after.
So it's like,
just keep your awareness there.
Keep it like don't give up,
and then you'll get
a little piece of the puzzle.